anywhere you're playing this please
enjoy I've been with you since before
200k but I haven't really had the time
to make you happy was level I'm sorry
for that but here it is D well the kids
gone on the balls thank you Mike space
bear Wow ok once more for just good
measure
flip dick it impossible kill all the
kiddies if Mark plays this my face will
explode boom well there you go just like
these poor unsuspecting people I think
that was the winner's circle but it
didn't register I'm not a winner in my
mind
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey whoa hey whoa hey tiny like sim is
up there but I don't know hey okay what
now landmine I saw it
okay there goes my boy I guess okay well
there goes my son forgot about it won
the world gods Pro dodge dodge again I
think you got something but I'm not sure
yep nope you got nothing apparently I
didn't need that leg anyway I got all
the pedaling power in my left one market
lar spewer oh I love it oh my goodness
it's so cute who am i killing oh that's
what I'm always here to help you mark
thank you too
kind of disturbing but hey it is okay
it's so cute
what's with the Panda is that a panda I
think I won
thank you many legends you're awesome
[Music]
markiplier adventure with tiny buxom
okay I just got to be really really
careful it's like some horrible butchers
machine markiplier saw well I think
you're spike fall was a little bit
backwards over there so I don't think
it's gonna be I've never heard that
sound before in my entire life have to
save Tiny Tim I will forget my son I
only care about Tim
[Music]
welcome to a choose your own adventure
game you will choose your own fate but
beware for even the slightest mistake
could get you killed
enjoy Oh once you go down there's no
going back well I mean if I wanted to
play the game I need to play your level
collect tiny bug Sims for attacking
advantages yay I tried to take a stroll
in rain old house in the industry creaky
old house had to go to the basement duh
of course who wouldn't go to the
basement you walk down the old stairs
the basement sends a chill up your back
it is quite dark in the basement - you
find a flashlight to turn it on you see
a shadowy figure ahead try to read it
there's nobody upstairs yeah I thought
you could fool me huh that's what I
thought well as it drags you down and
pulls you back to the corner base and
sucks your soul out wait alright so I
got the flashlight and there's a shadowy
figure ahead obviously I need to go
towards it because I'm not wimpy enough
to run away you step closer and the
thing spots you as you continue to get
closer
ok so apparently I was supposed to go
upstairs because we're all judgey
judgmental cherries you head upstairs to
see two rooms a bedroom and a bathroom
you decide to go to the bedroom cuz why
would anyone go to the bathroom in
horror game end of the bedroom take a
nap well what is this [ __ ] ok so I
go to the bathroom this time and this is
going to leave me you go inside the
bathroom then shrug and leave play this
one time to get ready to play minecraft
wart that beer in my mouth oh my
goodness haha
[Music]
the world no Tim don't eat Tim -
markiplier poopie you stay away from me
hah I don't even need to dodge over your
scar okay so apparently there's an
obstacle in my way that I need to not
die from no death was so close Oh
markiplier save tiny box simple no I
will save you I have to save Tim where
did you take him - alrighty then who
would dare capture tiny box Tim Michael
are fun run
Oh cold kitties were going for a fun run
it's everyone is totally fine which is
good you know about my heart is if you
want to know about my Oh
[Music]
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you want to see
more happy wheels right now check the
description or click the annotation for
the full happy wheels playlist and if
you want to see more happy wheels in the
future please click the like button to
let me know thanks again everyone and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye